well I talk about a lot of different
layers in the book one of the things
that everybody gloms onto is the art of
SNM because you know obviously I i
phrased that in a way that would be
provocative and what I'm really trying
to say is that women who are trying to
reach men and get men to help them you
know succeed in whatever whatever level
they're at sometimes we have to do more
than just play by the rules and the
rules are be smart be passionate be work
hard you know do everything right don't
have an agenda get the job done we do
that women do that that's why we're in
the business in such great numbers but
in order to get above that middle
management level we have to kind of use
some invisible persuasion or
manipulation is what I say and then and
that is to try and get the men to
approve of your ambition and to enter
and to give you the advancements that
you're looking for and it started kind
of an unorthodox way and I you know
people may not want to use the tactics
that I use that worked for me and all
I'm saying to women are think of your
own tactics so everything's not black
and white you know men are not that hard
you know they're kind of and they
admitted themselves they're they're kind
of easy we know how to deal with men in
our personal lives we start with our
Father we have brothers we have husbands
we have boyfriends we have we can we
have no problem dealing with those men
then when we go into the workforce and
we have men that were in business with
we just kind of lose everything that we
know and we become you know kind of
slaves to their set of rules and I'm
just saying seduction and manipulation
seductions not about sex it's a metaphor
you try and manipulate the situation and
control the situation you are in in a
charming way that's not threatening and
in a way that makes people admire you
and care about you rather than dismiss
you